citizens of the reject Nation we are
going to watch House of the Dragon
episode 7 today Johnny how are you I am
excited for this how are you excited for
this how are you I'm excited for this
even more so this yes
excitement House of the dragon ladies
and gentlemen leave a like jacars that
like button also subscribe and click the
notification Bell to get notified when
our reaction for episode 8 is up here on
the channel and also uh full anthraction
watch Longs resync with your own copy
for us the dragon available for a super
sexy Rejects at our patreon page also
covers several shows over there
exclusively with reaction highlights and
watch alongs included lastly the team of
prepper thank you for helping us set it
down these highlights and you guys are
kicking so much booty let's get to it
foreign
[Music]
wow that's like directed right at him
babies
oh
that's not our blood is it
[Music]
it's great contrast
first one starts with the birth
son starts at the burial it's good
observation
your girls have a very image of their
mother
a comfort and an anguish as I will
remember
the gods can be cruel
it seems they've been especially cruel
to you
there's a place for you in my court but
something you should need I need
nothing
sorry for your loss my friends
and Damon grieving scary no one rocks
disheveled like recess
this guy seems like a creepy Finn
wolfhard exact that is a hundred percent
the five of us
perhaps the gods of squanders
it's not Justice for your wife that
drives you as your own ambition
I gave up the idea of wearing a crown a
generation ago it is you Lord husband
who refuses to abandon this Pursuit even
now the cost of our children
fries took this long and mentioned
this guide cannot handle truth bombs
tonight
doing his best but big denial Herron's
curse is said to be as strong now as it
was after the Congress it's a ghost
story
monster and the queen would gladly
exploit
I do not believe Alison's capable of
cold murder
each of us is capable of depravity
we have some depravity you'll need to be
more specific
so dark I know you abandoned me I spared
you you were a child yes I was a child
look at what my life became without you
I'm sorry don't be
I'm at least now to mow my losses
already
you know there could be Spies all over
this beach
[Music]
this whole situation is just pure
Darkness
symbolic setting and time of day
[Music]
until I have one blonde baby just
attended his wife's funeral gotta keep
the bloodline pure
pure as possible
oh
is he gonna try to claim that dragon
is he gonna uh go claim Veigar yeah oh
snap
what a move
foreign
dude bad bad move homie
[Music]
does not see you as a threat
[Music]
[Music]
wow that was a beautiful shot yeah
oh my god it worked geez I will call you
pig
the pink Fury
God everyone's just
jumping all over Elena's stuff on the
night of her parents
[Music]
oh my goodness this is
awesome
you really feel the proportions yeah
it's like 2014 Godzilla absolutely
thank you
I just screwed his head off
[Music]
[Music]
wow
he's just
there you go airplane classic shots
the airplane did not crash
where did you go man
that's how you prove yourself you just
come back with the biggest baddest
dragon
[Music]
[Music]
gorgeous
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
absolutely beautiful it's the anatomy
alone
my God
what if that was the opening someone
stole fake
there's a 60 Minute counter
the 24 episode
oh God
that belonged to his woman
maybe your cousins can find you a
picture ride
ouch have you learned nothing
whoa kids
damn
oh
thank God
really bad's about to happen
yep
no you won't die screaming your flame
stretches your father did bastards
alive
doesn't know does he oh strong
oh
[ __ ]
what
oh
what
let me see shut up at the right time
yeah
[Laughter]
oh my God this situation is so bad
wow
whatever he's got a big ass dragon out
yeah
and of course they show up together yeah
not suspicious at all lucery brought a
blade to the ambush kill my son it was
my sons who were attacked and forced to
defend themselves
Royal insults were levied against them
what insults
even my son's birth was put loudly to
question what coolest bastards
my sons are in line to inherit the Iron
Throne Your Grace this is the highest of
treasons
do where's Elena I wonder the boy's
father perhaps he might have something
to say in the matter I do not know your
grace I
I could not find sleep I'd gone out to
walk
[Music]
[Laughter]
who spoke these lies to you
oh oh God
in recycle
tell me the truth of it
this is escalating so fast yeah this is
happening
now make your apologies and show Good
Will to one another
uh your father your grand sire your king
demands it
look what you've done to me look at me
physically this is all new guys
Eamonn has been damaged permanently my
king Goodwill cannot make him whole I
know I listened
but I cannot restore his eye no because
it's been taken what would you have me
do I feel alone
I actually have one of her son's eyes in
return oh my God Alison yep
if the king will not seek Justice the
queen will well damn it's like I've been
avoiding this shiver a long time
you can have the crown buddy
man
that's some good [ __ ] right here
yep
[Music]
[Applause]
even too far
it's quite done but what was expected of
me
forever oh the fire right the dip you
take my son's bite into even that you
feel entitled exhausting wasn't it
hiding beneath the cloak of your
unrighteousness
[Laughter]
oh boy oh Oh that's oh dude just a wrist
very bad like the forearm straight down
looks like it yep
oh that's not good at all oh dude no
dude
I'm dragging I'm not getting the Dragon
this proceeding is at an end
I slept with renera
Arrow
Kirsten
oh my God dam is standing right there oh
[ __ ]
Family Feud
I saw this princess
I even doubted its existence it was an
ugly thing I regret it we play an ugly
game
and now for the first time I see that
you have the determination to Win It
let's face
now go to him be penitent
plead the injury to your son
be grip on your passions
and I promise you in time you and I
together will prevail
oh man
the boy was right it's worth a thousand
times the price he paid
dude she is brilliant yeah she is
brilliant
that horror of the person that she knows
is within her
that is disgusting this is really gross
[Laughter]
it sucks to live in this time I tell you
what damn that could have been fatal
yeah
oh my God useless what happened last
night
they were supposed to be mourning one
person
and it became about something else they
recommit myself to you
and to strengthening our house
for your Ascension I will raise our sons
to be princes of the realm you deserve
better than what I have been you deserve
a husband
so many bad things
just let them have this moment he's
gonna protect his sister so I'll protect
you
[Music]
it's like playing world's Waldo with
this creep yeah right it's always
working somewhere in the background
it is
balance the scales I am your servant
that will not be necessary
Allison's gonna search like a crazy
woman
they will doubtless come when I require
such a friend
skill but discretion
as well
I shall await to a call
my queen
[Music]
the choices we could not marry unless
lane or we're dead exactly
[Music]
oh There Are Places across the nearest
sea
where it doesn't matter what a man's
name is
we're asking of Me Lord
run away
well with Witnesses
you ought to be a strong Queen you must
cultivate lovely respect yes but your
subjects must fear you oh my god roll
through her why are you in my father's
Hall
you have always looked down on me
wow
[Music]
all around the guns
[Music]
there come the witnesses wow
oh my God and the realm will whisper
that I was somehow responsible
oh both the children
Jesus
[Music]
I've never seen love like this nope
we should all be so lucky
[Music]
oh my God children must be like holy
[ __ ] what a weird weekend this has been
for everybody
ah
yeah nice
run away
go live your life
did they burn that's a good question
maybe they
grabbed one of those nights or did his
ward make it out you still be attracted
to him even though he's bald he could
grow it back a couple years you know
that's all they got to do and they gotta
not you know capsize and die but yeah
I think they got a shot
man
they squeeze so much into this one hour
yeah so rich so much happened
rich and twisted this has so much so
much happened it's all happened like
24 hours
over the course of one night my God
one long night fairness Jesus did Miguel
saposhnick direct the uh the really dark
battle episode in season eight of Game
of Thrones I don't know I wonder if they
came back and he's like I want to do
this one all at night again except I
don't want to do it a little better you
can actually see stuff
talk about it Jesus all right so playing
this back looks like the guy's body's
the guy in the staircase who Damon
killed yeah makes sense
and all the skin all the epidermis was
burnt
oh man all right let's recap everything
that happened in this episode all right
here we go so one the funeral
two uh amen took Veigar yes and uh they
fight with the children sure and then uh
they Damon and I paneer made love Damon
made love I mean that's small in
comparison where it ends off with them
and then uh truths were coming out she
struck Allison struck
uh Rainer with a blade and then
Auto realized hey you got that
ruthlessness in you that you clearly are
uncomfortable with yeah but yeah we
could use that to win we need more of
that around here things suck you're
promoted and then they faked lenor's
death yep
and now
Damon and renero are married that's
that's a lot and somehow did not feel
rushed which shocks me because
the show it really does have a a tight
grip on on the moments it chooses to
capture and whatever emotion they need
to evoke and connect with its audience
because
somehow it's so damn effective and I
don't feel like I'm missing the only
thing I slightly feel like I missed out
on was you know there's so much mourning
happening at the funeral and I'm like I
kind of wish I knew Elena a little
better sure only so I could feel a
little bit more for this morning that
everyone's going through but it wasn't
really about the morning it was about
all the suspicious looks that everyone
gives that's what the show's fill with
it's suspicion throughout and uh
whatever conniving plans are percolating
everywhere
and guards are also terrible in the show
they always run way too late that's what
everyone does the altar cards
[Laughter]
I guess yeah like you're supposed to be
right outside the door right it's like I
don't know maybe they figure the hall is
empty or something like that uh you know
it's it's the kind of system where you
gotta you just gotta rely on hearing it
down the hall I guess
um but yeah a lot of these characters
became so much more interesting we
didn't really get to spend time with and
I like the compassionate touch they take
with
I mean I was I was doing wrong I'm down
for anyone taking some type of villain
just turn I don't give a [ __ ] I I I'm
I'm all game for it so if renera did end
up killing off Lenor I'd be like all
right I'm rolling with it
this is the Game of Thrones world right
here sure you do she's there now she's
bad what are you gonna do because as as
like uh self-pitying and uh at times
seemingly pathetic that linear can
sometimes come across as he's also a
nice guy he's a good guy you know he
still had a heart and he was still
trying you know and uh like I don't I
don't think he's holding company like I
don't think pathetic is really the the
right choice of words for it it's it's
the the way the Optics I'm talking about
can sometimes be perceived around the
gentleman right
and uh I I appreciated that conversation
that they did have about trying and how
renera actually like didn't really want
to die and there's also a demonstration
of the kind of I bet in the books
she actually killed him off I guess
I bet there's some change in the books
they took and they're like we can't ever
do that here uh but uh I'm curious we're
gonna ruffle some feathers by killing
his actual lover on ceremoniously like
the second we meet him in that one
episode so let's yeah let's give him a
happy ending let's let him go off and be
with his new lover because I get tidbits
of information but the you know I I
don't like to even if I start listening
like Paul heavy spoilers amazing
breakdowns and I I usually will I might
stop oh like towards like a few minutes
before his videos end because I'm always
a little hesitant of I don't want to
hear anyone go into what's going to
happen and he's pretty good about
avoiding that unless you're watching
like a trailer breakdown but but in
terms of the episode breakdown pretty
solid about avoiding that and uh so I
don't I don't like I don't know what's
going to happen I never know what's
going to happen with this show but I
know they will make some tweaks and and
for some reason I'm like
I feel like in the book she might have
done something messed up like that and I
could definitely see that yeah or maybe
if it wasn't her but either way you can
see yeah her wanting it to be that way
and Damon just being like no kill kill
him for real I mean it's there's so much
grieving happening in this episode and
it's like it and and the other part of
grieving is the phrase that comes to
mind of
the saying of good grief you know
like that's just that's just what king
viserys reminds me of I feel like every
waking moment is good grief it just
doesn't stop just just a womp womp just
a sad character
you just want you want the best for him
you know he wants the best for everybody
and yeah it's just uh this guy is so put
upon he's always deteriorating well I
feel like the last episode truly
highlighted like the standouts of where
the the setup of the you know renera and
Allison and where they're at in this
political war game and then here it was
it was like every like so many more
characters really got to shine and like
this was a true Mastery of an ensemble
piece I thought even the kids became
interesting I know beyond aegon being a
creepy Tyrant uh that hasn't really been
a tyrant lately just creepy he's really
creepy Eamonn
aiment yeah
aegon was just chilling drinking wine
creepy Finn wolfhard is aegon I think
and yeah aymond is yeah yeah aegon is a
creepy one
aegon yeah no Eamonn what do you mean
who charms the dragon and who gets zika
I wasn't talking about him no sorry was
creepy oh sure yeah I guess so and then
you corrected me oh I'm sorry I must
find Evan creepier because I thought
aegon was just chilling this whole
episode just be like what I just want to
drink wine aegon's always a creep one to
me I don't know Heyman doesn't really
creep me out uh he's he's got that
malicious like vindictive looking as I I
know I like that about him sure because
I mean the way they set up his character
though is he's bullied yeah and he's put
down upon it like you're the one without
a dragon Loser yeah and now you've got
the Ultimate Dragon if you've got the
dragon with the most seniority because I
I liked the way they did that where he
he wins over Veigar and it becomes this
glorious ride through the Seas
and then it instantly turns into just a
God damn nightmares
yeah they really are good at getting
that sense of like I don't know what's
gonna happen but I feel like something
terrible and like irreversible is about
to come and that's somehow surprising
you with what it is like and it is that
but it's not exactly I don't know I kept
expecting someone to be like paralyzed
or to die or something like that in that
moment well there's such good framing in
this show a phenomenal framing yeah like
that shot when when renera is talking
with like that is such a painting when
air is talking with Damon at the end and
she's saying because they both you know
she's married to Valerian he was married
to a Valerian like the the sister of her
husband and then you see like we have to
say goodbye like when you see in the
distance the ship sailing like we have
to say goodbye to the sea to this
bloodline and we have to we have to
marry Within
yeah you gotta make it even more pure
yeah I mean we'll keep these blurrying
kids you got but we'll keep these strong
kids yeah and Damon's valerians yeah
yeah exactly so I I just think that the
way they they compose this episode just
it's it it was it had this fascinating
pull where it starts off so mournful so
sorrowful in the beginning like really
deliberate as you're you're sinking into
the tension and the mood of this funeral
like this funeral should be all about
grieving
yet it's you could like that the thing
this has such a great Mastery of is
there's always a goddamn political war
game happening at every waking moment
and sneaking suspicions and whenever
there's a death it's like what's going
to happen next now yeah and then you
know you're you settle in with Damon and
renera rekindling that love and then it
kind of puts some other things in a
clearer perspective from prior episodes
where
you know like when he first like in the
brothel were Nero when he was uh making
the moves on her but then he couldn't
fully go through with it and the way he
was talking to her now it seems so
sincere
of
like you he did seem like he you know he
was tempted he wanted to
and he is drawn to her emotionally
and but he like he he wanted to
originally marry her
but he he couldn't he needed okay he
knew that there would pose a danger to
her yeah and so I was like oh okay that
makes a lot more sense now like some of
those choices that were made before
because you see him here now where he is
I don't know if the right word is
subdued but he he's not as like he still
has his ways where he'll start chuckling
about a thing that you don't expect him
to chuckle about or it'll be an [ __ ]
in a moment or or find something uh it
could be kind of kind of gleeful over
something that you wouldn't expect
someone to be gleeful over
but there is more of a sincerity I think
to the way he communicates but
especially with renera like I I bought
their
I bought their kindling I bought their
romance yeah I do too yeah and I like
the weird sort of back and forth Push
Pull they've done with it where yeah I
mean you can tell that they Parts them
really want this but also parts of them
are sort of uncomfortable about it
mostly because of you know the outside
View and it's an interesting Cornucopia
of feelings we get to have because
they're both uh Matt Smith and Millie
elcock and Matt Smith and um
oh goodness Emily Darcy uh they all have
great chemistry together and so yeah
it's like it's easy in the moments where
you're you forget the circumstances to
be like man they they really are kind of
faded for each other in a way but also
this is
yeah so conflicting and so kind of
squirmy and yeah it's it's a wonderful
portrait and I love an episode like like
the this felt more tense like we got
really uh sort of on edge during the
episode where uh uh they have the big
gathering in the hall and and all that
stuff goes down and Kristen kills the
the lover and all that stuff but here I
I felt even more tense because you are
boiled down to these are like the main
families involved with a lot of the
ruling right now and they're all in a
small room together and everyone's
either grieving or Furious for some
reason or is standing on top of a
mountain of like thinly veiled deceits
and it's yeah I love that feeling of
Like Anything could happen in this
moment and even when they were doing the
the you know the thingless uh Lenor I
remember thinking to myself like oh yeah
they're they're gonna arrange so that he
can you know steal away somehow and go
out and live with his because I I've you
know we've seen this guy who he pays off
at least one other time you know as sort
of mentioned as a a target of lane ore's
affections or or you know somebody who's
been spending time with and and so you
know as he's negotiating I was like okay
that's what they'll probably do but then
when they're actually doing the thing I
got so caught up in it and I was like
maybe they did just actually kill him
and and I feel like that's a testament
yeah to the overall sort of Paul of
uneasiness and anger and and grief
intention like it's a great it's a great
really uncomfortable and really sort of
sad cocktail yeah and I thought it was a
great choice to shoot this all at night
um because it is the time like you know
symbolically the time where everyone's a
little more a little less afraid to Bear
their true nature or true uh you know
desires and uh and just you know be a
bit more bold undercover of Shadow uh
and yeah like I loved I loved this sort
of weird not mad keptness but there was
a sort of like man this is there was so
much much happening over the course of
this one night but it instead of feeling
like just a whole like you said feeling
rushed it does feel just like a domino a
sort of like disconnected domino effect
that eventually collides one thing leads
to the next quite naturally yeah and
things that seem like they start off you
know completely disparate from each
other yeah pretty soon tie right in yeah
it's a fascinating chess game yeah I
mean there's so much to interpret about
how like everything that occurred at
night because there's there's so much
like things of lurking in the shadows
the darkness within giving in to those
deeds all coming out and so that's what
made that that uh argument and the
debate in the hall about what to do with
the kids you take this kid's eye and
then Allison exposing herself because
there's so much
secrecy is part of the politics here
there's so much things that are have to
be kept hidden or things you shouldn't
say things you shouldn't talk about and
so much of this was about confronting
truths you know even uh raynus talking
with uh Blake you know his name with
Kingwood
talking with cordless and him it's like
he always knew these truths but it's the
first time it would appear this is the
first time any of this is being said to
him like you keep you keep justifying
this pursuit of power to right to wrong
that happened to me but you want Power
yeah and you're you you gotta face facts
that's not our blood those babies
there's no way those are ours yes then
our kids man your bloodline carrying on
and then even uh even when it came down
to Lenor you know like the truth of the
matter is like he can't go through with
this much longer like he's deteriorating
so it's it's that kind of thing where
again it's not necessarily pathetic it's
the fact that none of this is this is
the most unreal for if for anyone this
is the most this is the biggest lie for
anyone you know because yeah Lorena can
put up the act of being in a marriage
and lie that these are
you know his kids but in a day
the truth is those are still her kids
you know yeah she still has something
she's still going to be Queen who
inherits like there's no there's not
much of a like she lies about who the
father is
but for him like this is all lie he's
got to like pretend like yeah these are
my children I love these children I love
my woman you know there's so much he's
got to do and none of this is is true
for him like whatsoever so him getting
to sail off I think is actually kind of
nice for him you know it's kind of
beautiful yeah yeah and and in the
greater conversation it's like oh cool
like I guess we're not going to see him
again but yeah at least this queer
character gets to have a happy ending
yeah thank God honestly Olivia like
everyone's great Emily Darcy's is is
amazing
and you you can feel that
I guess you could say you feel
that drive and anger the aggression
within them what I really love about
Olivia Cook's performance that's her
name right
yes who plays uh Allison yeah I believe
that is the older Allison yes um well
Allison what I love about her
performance is there is such a
uh a chaos within her she's always
seething yeah they're trying to keep a
lid on that yeah there's like a flood
gate waiting to open yeah within her and
that's the thing that makes her
performance
kind of scary because I know you don't
know when the pot's gonna boil over I
feel like every time her eyes well up
with tears I'm like I can feel the
cracks in the dam starting to form and
then even like the Loyalty with the
children I thought was great like when
aemon notices his mom is like this could
be bad for my mom if I confess that it
was my mom who told me that those
children are bastards
[Laughter]
talks his way through that like
[Laughter]
we gotta get a maester in here we gotta
find some way to verify this but I love
that he actually chose to do that and
again in a room where that could super
you get the real sense that that could
actually supersede all the all of the
pageantry and all the you know like um
the etiquette the the Cotillion of
accepting these lies we you know pretend
to be truth is just because of the law
of treasons and stuff like that like I
love that he's just like everyone in the
room could tell it's the elephant in the
room yeah and then you have uh Otto who
you can feel has a sense of Vengeance
out as well you know someone who was
wronged who feels wronged yeah and now
he's got like a a a a a disgusting drive
here because it's the same it's the same
goal it's the same end goal but now
there's like a sort of lividness to
enjoy the pursuit is now and like we're
gonna take this I'm gonna take it all
down so it's like where's the war
there's a war coming I don't know
exactly where is it going to be
valerians versus targaryens because it
kind of seems like we're headed there
you know oh I mean I feel like they're
all going to be pointed at each other
after a certain point because all of
these things are so tenuous and it's
also Regional and everything else well I
mean when you look at what happened with
my God I'm blanking on all the wrong
names right now uh cordless Uranus
what's the surname what's the Valerian
oh it is just valorian yeah there's
valarion which is their family name and
then there's Valyrian which is like the
old the race yeah yeah so Jew is like a
race and also a religion yeah yeah
exactly they're just they're the shoes
all right
Valerian yeah Corliss Valaria Valerian
okay
there's Valyrian blood in in all these
people deep down okay all right all
right yeah
valari that's right okay yes I remember
we had to be some sugar one episode yeah
all right so when you look at them
specifically cordless and Uranus
you know um Uranus was already feeling
like
Damon if if only like the part of her
grief was the blame side in that
discussion of if Damon had brought her
here we could have saved her yeah I
blamed Damon yeah and then even rhaenyra
points out that somehow this situation
with lane or they're gonna blame on
means in some way yeah and they've lost
both their children and they're probably
both failing like they've already felt
like Targaryen House Targaryen has
[ __ ] them over a lot already and now
they're completely poisoned the well
yeah yeah now they've lost both their
children
to them yes in some way there's an
association their loss is to them yeah
and they they don't even they they get
their two little girls but they don't
get really that perpetuation Of The
Bloodline they wanted through rainera
yeah it's wild stuff and uh
God I I have no I just have no clue
what's gonna happen and you know viserys
is gonna they're gonna give him a heart
attack like oh he's uh he's on the verge
of us yeah he's already had one he's on
the verge of going into a coma as of
this episode I think I'm just going to
assume that he will he will live till
the end of the season and just look more
and more terrible doing it because ever
like the last episode in this episode
and even that that first one where he
collapses at the time Jump I'm like he's
got to be dead now he's got to be about
to dice or someone's gonna kill him but
nope he just keeps on going and I feel
like that's the true curse of that
character is not only is he you know not
really cut out for King but also he's
just going to like live the worst way
possible for as long as possible before
he dies well he's such a pacifist and
dealing with a bunch of people who are
ready to wage war yeah within their own
selves and like I love when he starts
shouting you know I forget exactly what
but he's like is your father your
grandfather your king yes
shut it down I'm sick of this shake
hands and say you're sorry
this has to we're all friends again okay
yeah I mean I I feel I just feel
progressively bad for him yeah because
yeah he's dealing with this like leprosy
issue
um but it does feel like it's at least
with the filmmaking choice that it also
is a representation of him deteriorating
on the inside as well as as this
situation crumbles so does the head of
the whole thing him crumble as well
externally it's like when they show you
a picture of a president four years
later and they look like their hair's
all white and they've aged like 20 years
it's like that and this is the longer he
has to be king the more it's gonna suck
his soul out yeah and I I like the way
Allison because people oh you know
before when the show aired I had a lot
of people who are her fans of the book
you know um
I don't know about a lot but the the few
I know who read the book
would tell me like oh just wait at
Allison
the whole thing episode one don't trust
her
and I I think I don't know what it's
like in the I mean the read from what I
hear is often like multiple perspectives
and that you're
you know what like a lot of unreliable
narration yeah like a lot of Gossip
speak so with her you know I I wonder if
in the book it feels a little more black
and white with her because here I think
what makes her why well I'm loving the
performance so much is because you could
feel that there no there's a good person
in her
but the with the the ruthlessness is
slowly going to overtake is is Take
overtaking This Woman's Soul well
because she's yeah because I I think you
can see she fears what she's becoming
like yeah yeah and I feel like
throughout the performance it with both
actors there's often been that sense
under the surface in the performance of
like constant discomfort with most
scenes we see her in most conversations
we see are having to have most
situations she has to navigate through
and so I feel like that combined with
the hurt is creating this void that yeah
is gonna swallow up those better
instincts because yeah at least as of
the show when they're younger and I
think that's a nice part so effective
because you watch their loss of
Innocence yeah exactly so I I like the
show doing it this way because at the at
the top you know because people were
forming teams you know team green or
team uh and I feel like from the top of
this yeah you can see them both with
their innocence and you can see how they
are both victims of the situation and
then you watch as they grow and take you
know maturity and responsibility and how
they wield that in light of all those
things so if like the tragedy I think
plays really nicely here because yeah
you remember that girl who did seem like
she just wanted her friend you know and
and you know with whom they could forget
about all this kind of life-crushing
soul-crushing you know statecraft
nonsense yeah yeah you feel the tragedy
of her and the further like the more
confrontations they have you feel the
the smaller and smaller those Flames get
of their former Flames fire yeah
smaller those get of their former bonded
until pretty soon there's going to be
out entirely well fire is I I weirdly
like they were talking about they were
specifically talking about fire in this
episode and I I was thinking about it
too because whenever I do like work on
piece of fiction I notice I'll I'll end
up implementing something that has
something to do with fire and I did ask
myself like what is this fascination
with fire that I think a lot of people
have because it's dangerous it's violent
it can rage on but there's something
also beautiful and alluring
simultaneously about it you know and
there are small ways in which you can
harness it but it can easily overpower
anyone's control it's yeah it's a
volatile it could be volatile it could
resemble passion and then it could
resemble fury like there's so much to
fire it dances yeah exactly it it could
be unpredictable
uh so yeah I think there's there is
something like beautiful about it and it
does feel like a fire this whole episode
is this whole show is like a bit one big
fire it's like watching yeah it's like
watching a candle get knocked over and
then slowly as it spreads and engulfs
the entire house yeah yeah totally and
then you're like the candle engulfing a
castle Yeah 100 somebody leaves it next
to the wrong drape and then all of a
sudden you're just gonna pile of Ash One
Castle there's one candle yes cause all
this damage
and I love too that like we leave we
left off with Otto Hightower
in such a some in like a you know he's
conniving but in a sympathetic manner
where it's like oh damn he was just kind
of telling the truth and then he got
sacked for it and then I love on his
return episode it's like no he's like
yes you have come over to my side so
it's like it's a fun little like flip of
that table because yeah like as much as
we are kind of groomed not to trust him
at first they play you his sympathies as
he exits the first time and yeah comes
back fully well I I thought that would I
think we've seen so many stories where
like Sons become their fathers and it's
interesting watching one where you're
you're seeing Allison become her father
it's not something you really see a lot
of yeah and you're watching or near
become her uncle
the the more uh Stern Father Figure in
her life yeah no and and what that blend
will be like if any of that excess
Humanity will temper the autoness of how
she's growing you know because there's
so much of this I'm sure that has led
her as a character to look back and go
damn my dad was right you know I should
have trusted him all along
here I am this is wild yeah this is
sorted and and intense and I loved uh
Laris just constantly like I love that
he didn't really enter the episode at
all focally
but he's just always lurking and every
time you see him you're like what is
this guy's always got to be working on
something dastardly
man Allison man you're going crazy ass
like he's the kind of guy to come back
next episode and be like hey I took one
of the the Targaryen kids eyes because
you know I thought that's what you meant
when you told me not to do it you know I
could see him being one of those
characters I thought you were speaking
ironically
I feel like aegon's the one out of the
kids I feel like aegon's the one we're
gonna really hate or Eamon is the one
who you're gonna be like
you can kind of fear but you might be
you'd be more compelled to watch him
sure yeah yeah I mean he he seems like
he is growing into more of a bold
character thus far and even though we
saw him in a moment in that extreme like
I like the exchange of the cave because
you know they're they all have parts of
the truth they've caught from the table
above and you know they're all sort of
you know they haven't fully come into
the understanding of what all that stuff
means and so like the way that exchange
is charged makes a lot of sense you can
draw your own motivations as to who's in
the right who's in the wrong when and
how and it all gets kind of ugly and
they're all just sort of like fighting
and Furious but in a way where I'm like
I could totally see you know this is
just another one of those formative
moments where the next time we see the
kids and if there are more time jumps
involving them getting older I could
easily see how yeah like maybe Eamon
will come out as one of the more
interesting or one of the even more uh
copacetic characters in terms of like
who you might root for because you know
like renira's kids are gonna have to
grow up with feeling like Outsiders and
having people whispering them a lot I
can imagine they might become quite
bitter whereas Eamon you're more in a
position of like his kids bullied he's
just gotten like a major boost with
vegar so like just don't let that go too
far to your head and become you know
like the worst version of the thing you
used to be up against but yeah like even
with them I can see all this potential
for interesting storytelling yeah
yeah I think this is just great writing
because it's not just political Warfare
It's also family drama well yeah and
it's and and I think it still applies
but you know the further you go back in
history I feel like there's that it's
like you have warring Clans and factions
and and regions and you have yeah like
big scale War but you also have the wars
within each organization and within each
Alliance and you know all the you know
it's it's great it's like all the
different Venn diagrams that are
overlapping in the big circle of a war
you know and they're yeah they're
they're really graceful about how they
make sure that you're kind of abreast of
all those different motivations and plot
lines
well damn what'd you guys think of the
episode leave your thoughts down below
um I I never leave euphoric I just leave
with noticing I have more tension in my
shoulders than I normally every time I
leave yeah I'm feeling drained this
weird contemplation I have when I watch
it because I'm like oh am I feeling
stiff today and I'm like nah this show
this show just makes my shoulders tense
I haven't unclenched my face it's in six
minutes I've just my shoulder just hurt
this is a show where where I will forget
myself sometimes and I'll be like oh oh
my hands are still up or something like
that you know like some kind of reaction
yeah we'll like push you into a rigor
mortis for a while as you behold the
horrors unfold
all right guys we will be with you soon
thank you for being here
[Music]